neulich als für wichtig dass man auf die
ansteckungszahlen schaut ich glaube die
inzidenz alleine die ist in der
betrachtung ein bisschen zu wenig es
kommt auch immer darauf an wie viel wird
getestet wenn man wenig testet und man
hat weniger ansteckungsfälle dann heißt
das noch nicht dass alles gut ist wenn
man sehr sehr viel testet dann erwischt
man natürlich auch wesentlich mehr
symptomatische die dunkelziffer wird
kleiner die inzidenz steigt also ich
würde sagen die inzidenz alleine ist
noch nicht alles aber worauf haben wir
gehört natürlich ganz stark auf die
fallzahlen und die objektive situation
und die objektive situation war in
österreich schlicht und ergreifend das
nach sechs wochen lockt dann da lockte
seine wirkung verloren hat die menschen
haben sich immer weniger daran gehalten
es hat immer mehr verlagerung in den
privaten bereich gegeben und ein lockt
dann wo keiner mit macht der hat
natürlich auch wenig sinn wir kämpfen
jetzt seit einem jahr mit der pandemie
das ist zermürbend das ist anstrengend
viele menschen vereinsamen
wirtschaftliches ist eine extreme
belastung also dass da die menschen
unglücklich und unzufrieden sind das ist
ganz klar ich habe man muss sich aber
trotzdem immer die frage stellen was ist
die alternative
und die situation eskalieren zu lassen
eine situation die außer kontrolle ist
das kann keine positive alternative
seien wir alle müssen verhindern dass
die intensiv kapazitäten übergehen wir
müssen verhindern dass unzählige
menschen sterben die nicht sterben
müssten und insofern ist es notwendig
einfach in dieser pandemie dass wir uns
einschränken und dass wir maßnahmen
setzen
wenn wir es schaffen so eine europäische
lösung zusammen zu bringen sowie das
israel zum beispiel hat dann glaube ich
dass das gut wer denn dann können wir
dadurch auch die reisefreiheit die
freiheit wieder beruflich quer durch
europa unterwegs zu sein vor allem aber
auch die freiheit auf urlaub zu fahren
und kultur sport gastronomie all das zu
genießen dann können wir das auch wieder
sicherstellen und gewährleisten für den
sommer bin ich persönlich sehr
optimistisch an die durchimpfungsrate im
sommer wird eine
wir werden zur normalität zurückkehren
können und ich freue mich schon auf
viele menschen aus deutschland mit der
nämliche in kontakt bin die auch sagen
ja sie wollen im sommer endlich mal
wieder ihren urlaub in österreich
verbringen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren